well for those who don't follow football
the NFL playoffs are currently underway
uh my Baltimore Ravens are playing on
Saturday against the Houston Texans and
that's neither here nor there I just
want to mention it you know because I'm
excited about it uh much to my chrin
nobody in the audience cares about
football um you guys you don't care
about football and you don't care about
aliens and those are like half of the
things I care about and yet somehow we
make this relationship work you know I
don't know how we do it but we do so
anyway for the teams who didn't make the
playoffs um it's been a bit of a blood
bath for coaches uh lots of coaches are
getting fired you know as always happens
at the end of the end of this the
regular season um the difference is that
this time we got some legendary uh
coaches that are that are getting the
boot uh including bill bellich from the
New England Patriots after 475 years as
their head coach and after winning like
83 Super Bowls or whatever it was um
he's now gone and a few days ago his
replacement was announced and the guy
taking over is named gerro Mayo he's 37
years old he's a former player he has no
head coaching experience he has very
little coaching experience in general
and he's the guy they're bringing in to
take over the most successful uh you
know takeover for the most successful
NFL coach of all time so we'll see how
that works out um I'm guessing it will
work out very portly that's my
prediction in fact I'm even more sure
that it will work out portly after
watching the introductory press
conference for the new coach yesterday
gerod Mayo I guess we should mention now
is black and that's a fact that
shouldn't matter and shouldn't even be
notable especially in the NFL when like
70% of everybody in the NFL at every
level is black but it does matter
because it became of course a focal
point during the press conference which
in turn made the press conference a
subject of discussion on social media
with lots of people sharing their
opinions about it so first of all just
as
context um this is may be worth noting
that Mayo explained in his opening
remarks that after retiring from the
Patriots as a player he was first a
player and now as a coach but as
retiring as a player he initially left
football and went to go work in the
financial field and it was while working
in finance that he learned a valuable
lesson that will help him as an NFL
coach and here he is explaining that
lesson I took a break I went to opum I
needed a break from Bill I went to opum
for about four years and I came back and
one thing I came back with I learned a
lot at opum Larry rro Mike Matteo those
guys I learned a lot at at
opum about diversity right about
diversity and inclusion and you better
believe it being the first black coach
here in New England means a lot to me um
but those guys taught me you have to
take ideas from other people black white
green yellow it really doesn't matter
old
young yes this is an NFL head coach
taking over for the greatest coaching
legend in the history of the sport
explaining how we learned about the
importance of diversity an inclusion
while working in
finance if if you're if you are a
Patriots fan it's hard to imagine a more
discouraging thing to hear from the new
head coach of your team I mean there are
worse things I guess he could have said
that he learned about diversity
inclusion from you know watching Dylan
mulany Tik toks uh I mean they could
have actually hired Dylan mulany to
coach the team that that would be worst
of all we're not quite there yet we'll
be there in a few years so um that's
where we are now but in any event this
comment about diversity and inclusion I
think lends some context to what
happened next during the media questions
uh during that portion of the event when
they took questions mayo and the owner
of the team Robert Craft were asked of
course about the significance of mayo
being a black head coach and Robert
Craft gave basically a good answer he
said that he hired the best man for the
job and that man just so happened to be
black he said that Mayo's color is not
relevant to him like he wasn't looking
to hire a black man he was just looking
to hire the best guy and this is the
best guy in his opinion happens to be
black uh it doesn't matter so that's the
right answer like that's the correct
answer that's a good
answer I don't know if it's true you
know I don't know if that's actually
accurate um I'm not sure if they hired
the best man for the job or if they were
looking to make a diversity higher we do
know that the NFL does a whole hell of a
lot to incentivize slforce teams to at
least consider quote unquote minority it
candidates and I have to say quote
unquote minority candidates because
again in the context of the NFL black
men are not the minority so those are
not minority candidates by any stretch
of the imagination in the NFL but anyway
um that's the answer that he gave and uh
we have no reason to believe that it's
not
true but D Mayo himself had a different
take um in fact in his answer he kind of
rebuked indirectly the owner who was
sitting right next to him and he said
this
listen I do see color because I believe
if you don't see color you can't see
racism and whatever whatever happens
black white disabled person I've always
even someone with disabilities I always
uh you know for the most part people are
like you know don't you know when
they're young they they kind of make the
spot hot younger people know what that
means but what I would say is like no I
want you to be able to go up to those
people and really understand those
people so it goes back to whatever it is
black white yellow it really doesn't
matter but it does matter so we can try
to fix a problem that we all know we
have okay now as I said that clip went
viral and um lots of people did not like
Mayo's statement that he does see color
like that's the thing people are kind of
focusing in on is that he said he that
he does see color but that's not the
problem here okay that is not the issue
with what he said of course he sees
color we all do like we all notice the
races of the people that we are
interacting with um said say that you
don't see color is it's it's nonsensical
like saying you don't see height well I
don't see height I don't even notice
like of course you notice it if
somebody's short you notice it if
somebody's tall you notice of course you
do um in fact every time you look at
someone you notice these facts about
them there's nothing wrong with that we
don't have to pretend uh and should not
pretend that we don't notice other
people's races it's completely silly so
that part is
fine the rest is the problem because
first the reason reason why he says he
sees color is um is you know well if the
reason had been well I do see color
because I have eyes and it's a fact
about someone that I can see and so I do
see color if he had said that then that
would be fine but instead he says that
he sees color so that he can stop racism
well it's 2024 and a lot of us are
trying to uh get our finances in order
there's some great news for homeowners
though interest rates have dropped down
to the fives a lot lower than they were
last year if you've been buried in
highin credit card debt now now is the
time to Break Free with American
financing American financing can help
you access the cash in your home to pay
off your high interest debt last year
the salary based mortgage consultants
helped customers save an average of $854
a month that's like giving yourself a
$10,000 raise and that's a way to start
the new year in style if you start it
today you may be able to delay two
mortgage payments so call American
financing today at 866 569 4711 that's
8665695076
s182 334 nmls consumer access.org APR
for rates in the five start at
6.27% for well-qualified buyers call 800
685-5627
years
old and has been a star athlete all his
life he is unlikely to have ever
encountered very much racism okay and
and in fact it's like almost all but
guaranteed that I have encountered more
racism than he has in fact that's like
definite um and in the context of of
being an NFL player like as an NFL
player and now coach you're not
encountering any racism at all ever like
you just it's it just doesn't exist
there um yet he's constantly on the
lookout for it he says and
this is what it means to Value diversity
and inclusion after all I mean that's
what it means he said he values
diversity and inclusion and now he's
explaining what that means and this is
what they taught him in finance instead
of teaching him you know Finance also
just the idea that there's anything
significant at all about hiring a black
coach is of course absurd again 70% of
the NFL is black or more there are many
black coaches there are plenty of black
head coaches in the history of the
league and today now there are fewer
black head coaches by proportion um
which who cares just like there's fewer
white people by proportion in pretty
much every other position uh in the NFL
or on the sidelines but how do you end
up with more white head coaches than
black wals because a black person who is
involved at football and interested in
football uh at that level is just more
likely to get into the business as a
player um and and like going back you
know going back through childhood
if you have a if you have a a black
child is very interested in football
it's the proportions tell us it's more
likely that they're going to get
involved as a player whereas with if you
have a white kid and plenty of white
kids that play football but as you go up
and up and up um it it becomes a less
and less white sport shall we say and so
if you for for for white people if they
want to remain involved in the sport at
that level the more likely to do it on
the sidelines like that's just that's
that's the way it works out um and you
know both groups are making millions of
dollars uh both are doing fine whether
they're players or coaches so we don't
have to worry about either one of them
and there's no racism involved here but
the greater issue I think is just the
idea that we need this guy to
pontificate about racial issues in the
first place I mean listen to what he
said listen to what he actually said so
I took the liberty of transcribing it
and here's what he actually
said quote
whatever happens black white disabled
person I've always even somebody with
disabilities I always for the most part
people are like you know when you're
young they kind of make the spot hot
younger people know what that means but
I would say what I would say is like no
I want you to be able to go up to these
people and really understand these
people so it goes back to whatever it is
black white yellow it really doesn't
matter but it does matter so we can try
to fix the problem that we all know we
have I'm not trying to be funny here I I
have no idea what any of that means okay
there's not one coherent thought in that
whole jumble it's just babbling nonsense
doesn't mean
anything we understand the basic gist
that he's trying to articulate some
anti-racism thing because he starts off
by saying I do see color we got to spot
racism like that part and so that we can
guess that the rest of it is trying to
elaborate on that point but it doesn't
actually make any sense um you know if I
if I were to read you that transcript
and without any context you you would
honestly again not trying to be funny
you would honestly assume that I'm
reading a transcript from somebody who
was having a stroke or you would think
it was a Joe Biden speech which is which
is basically the same thing now here's
the
point I don't blame Gerard
Mayo for for that uh he's a football
coach he was a player before that and
for all I know he'll be a great football
coach again I'm skeptical of hiring
somebody with such little experience uh
to replace specialist the most legendary
NFL coach of all time but he could end
up being plenty of coaches that have
been hired at that age not and end up
being a great coach so it could be a
great coach um uh he he knows plenty
about football uh he knows a lot more
than I do about it but he's not a social
commentator okay he's not a philosopher
that's why we don't need anytime you got
any of these people in sports like with
very rare exception very rare except
most of the time you get these people in
sports they're asked some question at a
press conference tell us about the
significance of the racial this and that
what they have to say is if you can even
understand what they're trying to say
it's like the dumbest thing you've ever
heard because this is not this is not
what these uh people this is not their
job right and this is not they they live
their lives obsessed with football this
all they think about is football which
makes a lot of sense if you're in the
football
business um but we don't need these guys
to give us sermons and in fact it would
just be better if they didn't it it
really would be
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there